the iPhone 15 Ultra is going to be
better than you think in terms of both
the performance and the design because
I've been working with renders by
Shailesh on Twitter to create the
perfect design that I think is going to
look like based on all of the recent
leaks and rumors as well as some old
ones that I think are actually going to
come true and no it's not going to look
something like this really weird and
outlandish design on Twitter or
especially this one with a display on
the back that's absolutely ridiculous
it's not coming not even this recent one
with this really weird camera window
over on the right side with what looks
to be I don't know speaker or microphone
grills like what the heck is this it's
not going to look like these guys and I
also believe it's not going to look as
simple as this with the current 14 pro
Max camera design with simply the
rounded edges as you can see because we
did get some rumors that these edges are
going to be round it on the back for a
more convenient feel and of course those
leaks came from shrimp Apple Pro on
Twitter saying that the iPhone 15 could
feature a titanium chassis with curved
rear edges that's where it stemmed from
now shrimp actually commented on these
recent renders saying that they lack
something very important and that is of
course the Periscope camera which has
been rumored to come out next year
according to mention quo next year's
iPhone 15 Pro Max will get a new 12
megapixel telephoto lens with 6X optical
zoom and sensor shift stabilization so
as you know right now we have a 3X
Optical camera on the 14 pro but we're
gonna be getting a 6X and the only way
to make that possible is to use a
periscope lens if you don't know what
that is this is what it looks like
basically you have the entire lens
incense sir buried inside of the phone
with a mirror reflecting the light
basically going into the sensor like
this and the leaks and rumors are
showing that we're going to be getting
that next year with a 6X optical zoom
lens and that's basically why I disagree
with some of the renders like this that
show the exact same camera layout
because they're not showing the new
Periscope lens now there is one possible
way to make it work like this which I'm
going to reveal a little bit later on in
this video and it might be a genius
solution but it also might not work now
of course you've probably seen some of
the renders like this with a four camera
layout but it is actually not possible
to do this and let me explain why a
layout like this there's just no way it
can happen what you're seeing right here
is an actual x-ray image of an iPhone 14
pro Max now if you didn't already know
he here is the camera module this entire
kind of block right here it's all just
one encapsulated module and these
sensors are big the cameras themselves
are big so much so that they fill up the
entire thickness of the iPhone internals
all the way through so if we had four
camera lenses like this it would
actually be impossible because right
here is the selfie cameras and sensors
for face ID with the dynamic Island so
you literally cannot physically put a
lens up here it would be in the way of
the selfie cameras so that is why Apple
has this iconic design with this triple
camera lens with it kind of down here in
this triangle formation and you can
actually see the reverse of that x-ray
kind of flipped here you see this entire
encapsulated camera module with this
selfie camera setup right here so of
course you can't put anything up here so
the idea is where do you put a periscope
lens like this one this is actually from
the pixel 7 Pro from Jerry rig
everything and his tear down you can see
the design of the Periscope you can see
the lens glass with the mirror
reflecting out to the right you have all
of the lenses here and then this
squarish thing is the sensor that is
mounted sideways so essentially light
enters through the glass goes through
the mirror reflects and goes right into
the sensor that's how a periscope lens
works and that's how it's going to work
on the new iPhone 15 Ultra or per Max so
essentially the only place they can
realistically fit that long Periscope
lens is not going to be at the top it
could either be on the right of this
lens or over in this general area now
there was somebody that made this render
from November 12 2021 where they showed
that Periscope lens down here and of
course it reflects towards the right but
I totally disagree with this design I
don't think it's going to happen because
the battery is actually down here and
they don't want to impede on the battery
size so with that said let me finally
reveal to you guys my renders that I
created with renders by shy lash check
it out and boom there you go in this
nice copper bronze color now you might
think whoa this is really weird and this
is different but I'm going to explain
every aspect of this design including
the curved glass on the back yes not the
metal is curve but I believe the glass
itself is going to curve and you might
think that's nuts because it's going to
crack but there's a very good reason for
that and apple actually pre-planned for
that you could see that the lenses stick
out and you can see some differences in
the actual lidar scanner The Flash and
the new window for the Periscope lens
but first just check out all of these
different colors we have this new Kind
of Blue wish color right here we of
course have this render showing off the
bottom with the curved glass peeking out
and the USBC Port you can see this nice
close-up right here oh man this looks
really really clean and my personal
favorite is this silver check that out
we've got white on the back silver on
the sides and if you can't tell this is
actually a titanium metal finish that we
have and that's of course because we
have the leaks of titanium and shrimp
bubble Pro actually posted recently a
new titanium finish supposedly going up
on weibo this is actually the texture of
the titanium of the 15 Ultra and then I
absolutely love this shot this render
that shylash created he just did such a
good job go ahead and follow him on
Twitter but now let me explain all of
this and what's going on here and this
actually brings me back to an old leak
from John Prosser who said that there's
going to be a protruding flat glass
panel on the back of the iPhone 14 which
of course that got delayed so now it's
going to be the iPhone 15 but I
basically took his designer on and
instead of having the camera modules
flush with the glass my take was that
they would actually stick out because
the cameras are going to get bigger and
thicker especially with the 48 megapixel
camera sensor that we got of course in
the 14 pro but I believe the front is
going to stay the same it's not going to
protrude on the new one it's going to be
protruding on the back but now ever
since we got those leaks on rumors of
the back actually being rounded my idea
is what if John Prosser was right the
back is going to protrude however the
glass itself is going to curve into the
frame like this for a nice glass feel on
the back of the iPhone with everything
being textured it's not going to be
glossy anymore and a very important
aspect of this design is that this
etched glass squarish bump is going to
disappear essentially instead of all of
this being etched down it's going to be
a flat panel all the way to the top of
basically this glass window it's all
going to be thick and flat with the
camera bumps sticking out like it is
here and that's important because it's
going to allow Apple to make these
cameras even bigger than they are on the
14 pro so all of them are going to be
bigger and that's going to give more
room for everything to fit nicely so now
before I explain what's going on here
with the lidar relocation The Flash the
microphone Hull going up and this new
window for the Periscope camera before I
show you guys that stuff let me explain
why I believe the back glass is going to
be flush and curved around well if you
didn't already know Apple has recently
changed the design or the way they
designed the iPhone 14 pro Max to where
they can actually access everything from
the back of the iPhone this time without
having to completely take everything
apart like they did with the 13 Pro and
the other years now it's much easier to
replace the back glass panel and much
cheaper so I believe Apple made that
change to prepare for this new redesign
where you have the more exposed glass
that curves around and gives you a nice
really nice feel I believe this looks
just so much better than we have right
now this is super clean flat glass panel
on the back basically giving more room
for everything to fit in there and
there's even a chance that this glass
panel won't be completely thick on the
inside there's a chance they could
actually etch the inside of the glass
panel to give more internal space almost
like scooping it like a bowl on the
inside and you won't be able to notice
because the outside is painted like this
but on the inside there could be more
internal space so that's a pretty key
important part that's going to allow
everything to basically fit more nicely
and of course with a matte glass texture
this phone is going to feel amazing it's
going to be more fragile but it's going
to feel amazing now let me get into
explaining these different aspects right
here now in my initial renders that I
created with him I had the periscope at
the top before I realized that it's
actually not possible to fit this
Periscope design on the inside because
this Periscope camera is going to be
really thick basically encapsulating the
full thickness of the iPhone because you
have to have a side mounted sensor and
because of the X-ray that I later looked
at I realized it's impossible to put a
periscope here there's just too much of
these selfie cameras there there's no
way so that's why I flipped everything
and I put it towards the bottom where
you can see on this x-ray if you have
the Periscope here you could have it go
out sideways here all Apple would have
to do is kind of redesign the logic
board and make a cutout where it goes
around that Periscope camera and then
they could actually make it fit so this
right here is what we ended up with you
have the Periscope on the bottom you
have all of the glass elements going
through to the right apple is going to
redesign the logic board on the inside
to make everything getting fit and of
course it still looks very nice and
clean if you completely hate it or
disagree with me let me know in the
comment section below but if you enjoy
these new renders and you like them
please share them online share them
around see what other people think and
click the circle above to subscribe for
more videos like this one thanks for
watching and we'll see you in the next
video
[Music]